يقارن باخموت بهيروشيما مدينتان تعرضتا
للتدمير وضعت ملامحهما تقريبا باخمه
وهيروشيما لكن الزائره الاخيره حاول الربط
بينهما
[موسيقى]
استطيع القول بصراحه ان صوره هيروشيما
المدمره تذكرني بباخمت وغيرها من المدن
المماثله لا يوجد شيء على الاطلاق تم
تدمير جميع المباني لا يمكن حتى ادراك
اماكن الشوارع والمباني هذا دمار كامل
مطلق لا يوجد شيء ولا يوجد بشر
هيروشيما قصفت بقنبله ذريه في السادس من
اغسطس عام
1945 قتل فيها 140 الفا نصفهم مباشره
والنصف الاخر جراء الاثار النوويه
ضخمه الاوكرانيه رزحت لاشهر تحت قتال
دمرها بالكامل تقريبا كان فيها 70 الف
نسمه فرو وتحولت المدينه لمنطقه عسكريه
مغلقه عدد قتلى باخموت يتوقع ان يتجاوز
عدد سكانها قبل القتال زيلينسكي طالب
بالحساب عما حدث في باخمت لكن فاته ان
هيروشيما كذلك لم تعرف طريقا للقصص
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات